y como ya lo adelantábamos hoy nos
enfocamos en venezuela y con nuestro
primer invitado del día analizamos el
papel que juega eeuu en la extradición y
el pedido de extradición de tres figuras
clave del chavismo primero en la
audiencia nacional de españa aprobó la
extradición de la ex tesorera del
chavismo claudia patricia díaz guillén
hacia eeuu díaz guillén quien también
fue enfermera de hugo chávez de
solicitada en ese país norteamericano
acusada de delitos de lavado de dinero y
también organización criminal la
justicia española también aprobó la
entrega de hugo carvajal un ex jefe de
espionaje chavista y cabo verde envió a
miami a alexa como ya lo habíamos en las
imágenes de un empresario colombiano
vinculado al gobierno del presidente
actual nicolás maduro ya sabes acusado
de lavado de dinero en eeuu y para
analizar todo este panorama quiero
saludar en este momento a roberto denise
periodista de investigación en armando
punto info gracias roberto por estar con
nosotros en directo américa en francia
24 la gran pregunta es podría la
justicia de eeuu convertirse de hecho en
una especie de tribunal sobre el
chavismo con la extradición en vídeo
extradición de estas tres fichas claves
a ver creo que son todos los tres
procesos distintos en principio no están
relacionados aunque sí terminan teniendo
digamos algún punto de conexión y
lamentablemente muchos de estos casos de
grandes esquemas de corrupción que han
ocurrido con funcionarios venezolanos o
empresarios muy cercanos al poder
venezolano no se pueden ventilar o no se
han ventilado en el sistema judicial
venezolano completamente cortado por el
chavismo y muchos han terminados en
cortes en cortes internacionales en este
caso los tres en eeuu tanto al pollo
carvajal ex jefe de la inteligencia
durante la presidencia de hugo chávez
así como a claudia díaz también con
cargos importantísimos tesorera nacional
tenían digamos causas abiertas en los
eeuu por esquemas de ella por esquemas
de corrupción internacional y el por
caso narcotráfico desde hace varios años
pero ambos habían terminado en españa
intentando evitar esa extradición y el
caso de saab es más reciente toca
directamente digamos a nicolás maduro a
su periodo a él como figura política y
se remonta una acusación por desde
mediados de 2019 en un tribunal de
florida así es roberto ahí ya puso
entonces los tres temas sobre la mesa
estos tres personajes claves que vamos a
ir desarrollando pero antes quiero
preguntarle si estos tres procesos como
usted lo dijo son diferentes pero al
final son tres personas que estaban
vinculadas a la cúpula del poder del
gobierno venezolano con el presi con el
ex presidente hugo chávez y ahora con
nicolás maduro le pregunto si podrían
ellos destapar una información
comprometedora para el gobierno de
venezuela
creo que hay mucha expectativa con eso
digamos la persona que quizás en este
momento tiene información más valiosa
además no sólo por la cercanía que tenía
con nicolás maduro me refiero a alexa
que se había convertido los últimos años
que hace que en una especie de ministro
plenipotenciario en la sombra
creo que sí puede ser una información
muy valiosa como digo sobre esquemas de
corrupción creo que en el caso de alexa
puede haber información que tiene que
ver con el entorno financiero de la
familia del propio nicolás maduro y creo
que eso explica también la preocupación
que hemos visto en el nicolás maduro y
en el chavismo los últimos días a raíz
de la extra dicción de alexa casi que
los tres procesos están terminando
ocurriendo en simultáneo pese a que las
acusaciones son distintas y se remontan
a años distintos pero digamos que la
preocupación a nicolás maduro se la
hemos visto en concreto por la figura de
alexa en el caso del pollo carvajal creo
que sin lugar a duda el pollo carvajal
puede tener información muy reveladora
también sobre esquemas de corrupción
pero también sobre y ya él ha sumado
algo está en españa sobre lo que fue ese
esquema de financiamiento ilegal de
campañas políticas internacionales que
buscó hugo chávez tanto en la región
como en europa
creo que el pollo carvajal tiene
información de eso y recordemos que sus
acusaciones por narcotráfico diría que
ver si finalmente el pollo carvajal
también tiene o está dispuesto a
colaborar y aportar información sobre
ese tema en los eeuu ahora roberto hay
ruido no entre la oposición venezolana
en torno a algo que pues quizá usted
pueda aclararle a la audiencia porque la
justicia de eeuu retiró siete de los
ocho cargos como parte del acuerdo de
extradición de alexa para que recordemos
está en el estado de la florida en la
ciudad de miami pero sigue siendo
acusado de conspiración para blanquear
este dinero según su expediente judicial
porque entonces la justicia de eeuu
retiró estos siete de los ocho cargos y
qué va a pasar entonces con alexa
la razón es sencilla las autoridades de
eeuu asumieron un compromiso con las
autoridades de cabo verde para que
pudiera ejecutarse la extradición y es
que el señor alexa no podía enfrentar
una pena una posible pena máxima que
supere la pena máxima a cabo verde
si álex hable dejaban todos los cargos
que tenía al final iba a sumar una pena
y en el caso de que lo hallaran culpable
podría sumar una pena muy larga porque
cada cada acusación podía enfrentar una
pena de 20 años en cabo verde la pena
máxima son 25 años esa es la única razón
que hay detrás de esto ciertamente ha
habido mucha mucha especulación incluso
la defensa de alexa sabía esto desde
hace tiempo recordemos que el abogado de
baltasar garzón que mientras él estuvo
en cabo verde ejerció de lecturas de
español ejercido como como una especie
de abogado internacional de alexa
lo había dicho lo había manifestado en
declaraciones que dio a la prensa
colombiana hace meses y era esa
reducción digamos de cargos por la que
finalmente eeuu lo iba a acusar como
digo
y el 15 de noviembre será la audiencia
en la que álex ar se aparentemente se va
a declarar no culpable y a partir de ahí
tendremos ya más certeza de cómo se va a
desenvolver este juicio ahora roberto
hablemos de esta mujer 9 claudia
patricia díaz guillén que no es tan
conocida popularmente porque deberíamos
prestarle atención al caso de ella ex a
que en específico a ver yo creo que
venezuela en los últimos años bajo bajo
el régimen chavista se ha convertido sin
lugar a dudas en una cleptocracia y hay
figuras emblemáticas de ésta
cleptocracia una de ellas es alexa pero
otra puede ser también la figura de
claudia díaz claudia díaz llegó a ser
tesorera de la nación nada más y nada
menos que tuvo cargos importantísimos
fue una mujer cercana a la figura del
propio hugo chávez pero siendo tesorero
de la nación participó en varios
esquemas de corrupción que tenían que
ver con las operaciones cambiarias
recordemos que venezuela durante muchos
años tuvo un estricto control de cambio
que se prestaba al arbitraje
con el valor de la divisa ella participó
de estos esquemas beneficiando ciertos
empresarios cercanos que luego pagaban
coimas y digamos favores a claudia díaz
y a su esposo también una figura cercana
a hugo chávez que también está en españa
a la espera de extradición un capitán
del ejército y como digo siendo una
figura tan que tuvo un cargo tan alto
nada más y nada menos tesoro de la
nación se prestó para estos esquemas a
ella ya en varias investigaciones
periodísticas se le han documentado
compras de propiedades de bienes
inmuebles por ejemplo en españa
valorados en varios millones de euros
cuentas bancarias en suiza donde
supuestamente estaba escondiendo parte
de este dinero que se benefició como
digo es emblemático por eso mismo en
venezuela es al final se ha convertido
en una plutocracia se ha desmantelado
completamente la institucionalidad y es
imposible que estos casos es pese a que
hay sobradas evidencias en prensa que
estos casos se terminen judicial izando
en el país